Maybe you've heard that Hebrew and
Arabic are written entirely in consonants
wrong.
Here's why
you're back in old Phoenicia where it
turns out the Greeks aren't the only ones
looking to buy a vowel. Your contact
in town is still your merchant frenemy.
Who reminds you of how
she traded your continent.
Alphabet across the ancient world.
That object spread to every language
with even a passing resemblance to
Phoenician. Every town from
here to Carthage has some
version of her object spot.
The Egyptians, those stuck in their
way. Traditionalist initially,
these submitted speakers, loved
it, they were proud of it,
but the days are turning to
years and that love grows cold.
They grumble that they're
stuck with these continents.
Just consonants clamoring for vowels.
They get desperate and grab a few
characters to stand in for a long sound.
Take a look. This symbol is originally
the stop between uh, ah, ah,
this one's a y. Uh, yes
sound and this is a Wa,
but they're about to become not these
things thanks to major moments in the
history of writing.
This moment hits you twice because it
brings up both in innovation specific to
submit scripts and a more
general principle that kind
of bins the rules of the
alphabet game.
First,
it's worth reiterating that object writing
systems are viable ways to write and
read a language they work,
but with one obvious shortcoming,
those missing vowels can
create ambiguous situations.
But what if instead of
writing every vowel,
we just had a few helpful hinders that
suggested the presence of certain kinds
of vowels. Take this letter, what
actually they called it? Wow.
Wow. Now imagine that we keep using
it in words that have the sound Wa,
but we also extend its use,
placing it between consonants for
the similar enough foul sound. Ooh,
in the old op job, you'd have to write
soon, and son with the same characters.
S plus in everything else is
vowels and we don't have those,
but suddenly our extended work comes in
handy. Son Doesn't have that ooo sound,
so it's still s plus in,
but soon does.
So we add in the WWE do
the same thing with Ja,
which can double as a long I and
this quirky catch in your throat.
Pause between uh oh a left,
which can double as a long awe and you
end up with three handy val suggestors,
the Matras Lectio, these helpful mothers
of reading that show up in Aramaic,
Hebrew, Arabic and Syriac that
these mothers don't leave.
They're consonant nus behind.
They still double as consonants.
The object traded the
ambiguity of a vowel.
This existence for new kinds of
ambiguity depending on context.
Each of these matrass may be a continent
or it might be a vowel one character,
multiple sounds.
This is a huge trend in alphabet.
Why invent new characters
when you can reuse an old one?
Repurposing continents for vowels
here and there won't satisfy everyone.
These bickering scribes aren't
content with mattress like the owners.
They're not just trying to
tell son apart from soon.
The bickering scribes are bickering over
how to read one of their most treasured
sayings.
One says that it's such a fine point.
You wouldn't understand unless you were
incredibly well versed in his language.
But he makes an analogy for you.
Write the word news and a continent
only alphabet. It's in ws. Fine.
Now imagine that someone comes along
with their fancy consonant vowel hybrids
and spells the word nous in w s hmm.
Wait a second. He shows you a cheat
sheet he's been keeping. It's so easy.
He says,
pointing out the little dots and dashes
above and below letters to keep his
vowel straight.
Put them here for an awe there for an a.
You can even add them below
one of the long vowel things.
If you need to distinguish, say an
eat, nobody's confused. That's it.
He won't tolerate the
vagueness any longer.
Effective immediately in all important
texts where clear reading matters.
Everyone's to use this method.
And so for generations,
scribes would mark bell's
above and below the consonants,
writing bowels in what was once
a consonant, only alphabet,
but as much as the pious and
students whereby they're Dadi vowels.
Modern Arabic and Hebrew speakers stick
with the simple continence plus the
extended consonant vowel mothers.
The optional helper dots get thrown in
like a life preserver for struggling
learners or careful text,
but grownups don't need them anymore.